oh wow you know you won your first Oscar
that night a well-deserved Oscar that
night but it is it is simultaneously in
many ways one of the best days of your
life and one of the worst days of your
life what has a journey been like since
that day my nephew you know we came home
and it's like he had stayed up late to
see his uncle will and he's on my lap
and he's holding the Oscar and he's just
like why did you hit that man Uncle will
that was a horrific night you know
there's many nuances and and
complexities to it you know at the end
of the day I just I lost it there's I
was going through something that night
not that that you know justifies my
behavior at all I would just say and you
know you're asking what did I learn it's
that we just got to be nice to each
other man it's hard and I guess the
thing that was most painful for me I
took my heart and made it hard for other
people you know and it's like I
understood the idea where they say hurt
people hurt people yeah